we're here at the Kapow comic convention
who are you and what have you come as
Holly and mrs. sassy and we're Hawkeye
and black widow from the New Avengers
film yeah so what was the inspiration
behind the costumes what which look have
you gone for in particular well this is
halfway between the film and the new
version in convert so he's just got the
purple symbol on the front because I
really like the really lovable code but
the purple question I always think is a
little silly maybe then the film one
that's awesome so and how about you well
actually she made this costume for me
this was forced on her tell us about
that you were so a real talent then for
costume making and design and stuff um
I'm a costume designer so it's kind of
well part-time job type thing and then I
do this is my hobby and far too much
time and money goes into it all any tips
I'm putting these kind of outfits
together learn how to use a machine and
learn have sew straight and then you can
do anything and then darts and then then
you're done how long does it take to put
something like this together
this one was two months about to my
house
yeah and that was about three days
it's mostly just waiting for things to
arrive the bass looking really good when
what are you kind of looking at today at
Kapow mostly just wandering around we
were here yesterday so we kind of looked
at lots of stuff and we're kind of
selling things is what I wasn't so
that's about your store
it's indie comics that you know
self-published sort of artists
collective called around town comics and
we have a lot of sort of all ages comics
sort of things for kids and adults
so you it's loop everybody likes do
something different you know how did you
get into all of this roads about 14 and
my friends invited me to go with them to
a convention and every need a costume
and so I made a costume and then it was
like a drug and it was bad and very
addictive could you see it when you go
and you're 14 you see everyone else
dressed up at their amazing ought to be
like there
you